august means special monthly treats at
pink box donuts jessica anderson vice
president of the brilliant
pink box marking okay she's here to tell
us what's up doc yeah you gotta say it
the right way and what's up doc
perfectly on cue perfectly on cue so
tell us what that means obviously we
have a bugs bunny inspired donut this
month it is a carrot cake doughnut with
cream cheese frosting sprinkled with his
favorite carrots yes
okay so before we get to the rest of the
donuts we're going to talk about them
don't worry let's go ahead and show them
how to make this one i think you're the
expert so i'm just going to let it
handle to you yes
so let's see your your donut decorating
skills here so wild cheese frosting
there you go you just got to get a good
touch oh yeah you got to get like that
good motion in there just a little bit
of rotation
see you got this girl i have faith in
you look at that wow i'm really not
doing that i'm really not
yeah now you got to top it off right you
don't want to disappoint bugs bunnies
you got to throw a little carrots on top
sprinkle on top yep
what a perfect august treat right like
that's
very bugs bunny approved right there
okay now for what i do best eating
donuts so i'm gonna try this one and
while i do that let's talk about the
care bears they're back absolutely care
bears are back this month in august we
have bedtime bear obviously we're doing
a lineup every single month of a care
bears bear feature so we have
bedtime bear this month next month is
going to be share bear which of course
with all the kids going back in school
in september good time to share and then
october is tenderheart so be sure to
come in check out our monthly care bears
donut they're friday through
sunday in our stores
and you don't want to miss out before it
goes away next month
and we also have awesome merch too so i
want to point out that we do have care
bears merch so not only can you
taste the tasty doughnut you can wear
you can wear and represent and hold them
okay pink bus you guys are so cute i
love that eating a donut with a care
bear yeah
this is my best nostalgic right now
now tell me you said this is just for
august correct that's our donut of the
month for august so you definitely want
to come in and try our carrot cake donut
it's so delicious and tasty this is an
amazing donut so make sure you hit up
pink box before this is gone jc i'll
send it to you